I worked this blaze near Big Timber
Montana and the blink of an eye just
fire everywhere and then charging out of
these flames comes this bear on fire it
was the most beautiful and terrible
thing I've ever seen I heard you guys
had some slots available being doing
here
I just had a daughter and I just really
want to give her what I never had if you
give me a chance I won't let you down
you know the difference between tattoo
crew and hotshots yes sir hotshots are
on the front line and they get to engage
the fire directly you guys are tied to
so why don't you do what you do best
stay in the back and I'm not Bob are
shit-talking you under your John or
anything
I've been trying it for over four years
got all our hours all our qualifications
sooner or later
fire is gonna come knocking in our
hometown but until we're certified my
crew won't even be able to set foot on
the line doing something that's never
been done before it takes time it's not
easy sharing a man with
we tell debris then this beautiful Vista
because once you're hot shot's you're
never gonna be able to look out into the
world see that pure beauty again the
fire gets past our line it goes to our
town no matter what you hear
[Music]
matter what's going on we can't go back
up there stand together
look out for each other
[Music]
no one could be prouder of his boys than
I am of you guys
[Music]
[Music]